I've caught the first two episodes I
thought they were really really well
done it totally pulled me in the first
thing I want to know is originally it
was called kita and then it obviously
got changed to high town
can you talk about why the change well I
think it's it's marketing wise I think
we all felt it was it was a more
interesting title so that's you know
it's all about you know bringing
bringing your show to the public and we
thought that was a little more
provocative a lot of times with the
series the opening credits are a
complete waste of time and I'm like just
get to it there's oh the credits on this
show are very well done I like the song
I like the visuals it has this energy
and it's selling what the series is can
you talk about crafting the opening
credits and what you guys wanted to
accomplish well you always want to lead
in your show with something interesting
to grab the viewer who turns deterrence
the Stars you want to keep them there so
this was a provocative way to do it it
took us a long time to get there
obviously we had different songs we had
different editorial versions but thanks
to Rebecca and Gary in the whole
production team they are editors and and
the people at starters were very helpful
in crafting it along with us we got it
done and it is very provocative I
thought Rachel did a really good job
filming the first two episodes can you
talk about why you wanted her to direct
those two well I worked with her she was
a DP on I think 12 strong she did some
additional shooting with us and she was
so smart session such insight into story
and character we'll work together and
the fact she has so much passion for the
project we were very fortunate that we
could convince her to do it
I believe you filmed for a few weeks in
Providence town when you were when you
were filming what were you going to do
if they said no we always figure out a
way to do it yeah you know we we we find
ways to get get things done did you film
all of your like exterior shots and
everything we needed for the 8 episodes
during that time so I guess you have all
your scripts done well obviously we did
a lot of a lot of filming there and and
did a lot of
I guess aerial stuff and and various
scenic scenes that we could use
throughout the seas throughout the
season so we have a nice Bank of stuff
from Thomas now when you were working
with stars and you coming in and you're
pitching it or developing it
how much are are they saying you okay
what's your plan for multiple years I
know we know you have a great first
season but do they want to know like you
have something that can go multiple
years oh absolutely you know we
certainly pitched out what we do and
then in the next season the third season
and then after after the season's over
then we really hunker down and come up
with where these characters are going
and with stories going and God the
second season is fantastic uh did you
I'm assuming stars it's happy with the
way it looks they're they're very happy
there I think they're putting out on
light after and energy behind it
marketing it and it gave us a lot of
their time during the production and
during the post-production there's a
great team they're very lucky to be
there please stay safe healthy and thank
you so much for your time
do the same thing thanks for being here
with us I really appreciate it